Nancy mace Republican Congress lady
she's a liberal Republican but
I kind of like her she's she's been on
the right side of at least a handful of
issues and
she's clearly a little bit lost and
trying to figure things out and that's
true of a lot of people in modern
culture well Nancy mace really stepped
in it because she showed up to the
National Prayer Breakfast and decided to
open her remarks with a joke about how
she almost fornicated before showing up
to the event
another year another standing room only
event
woke up this morning at seven I was
getting picked up at 7 45. Patrick my
fiance tried to pull me by my waist over
this morning in bed and I was like no
baby we don't got time for that this
morning uh I gotta get to the prayer
breakfast and I gotta be on time and a
little TMI but um I you know he can wait
he's got we got I'll see him later
tonight
um but I was here early today
it's just so cringe and this is the
defining feature of Nancy mace's
political persona
and it's it's very sad and she should
try to nip it in the bud and a lot of
other conservatives who are who are
tempted this way should nip it in the
bud too
it's not the sex stuff it's that she
always wants to be
the cool conservative she's like the mom
on Mean Girls she want I'm not a regular
Mom I'm a cool mom
I'm not a regular conservative I'm a
cool conservative I'm not a regular
Christian you know I'm a cool Christian
I almost fornicated with a man who's not
my husband this morning but don't worry
I'm gonna do it later tonight anyway
let's talk about God In Prayer ah man
good grief lady
just read the room
read the room and
recognize that there are more important
things in life than being considered
cool by the liberals who hate you
who hate you no matter how
irreverent you are no matter how much
you try to distinguish yourself from
your political party and the
conservatives and your supporters they
will never like you
you're a republican okay your your best
option to be cool is to reject the
standards of coolness of the liberal
culture which
Which Way lies Madness and which will
always hate you and to be a conservative
and she says she's a Christian
but but here's how she says it she says
when she was defending these remarks she
said I go to church because I'm a sinner
not a saint glad those in attendance
including Senator Tim Scott and my
pastor her pastor was in attendance
how disgraceful for him that she would
do this
took this joke in stride but what was it
a joke it was a joke in that she
intended for it to be funny but I don't
think she's joking that she sleeps with
her fiance I think that part unless
maybe she was joking about that and it
was all just a whole bit but I don't
think it is judging by her other
comments because Pastor Greg of course
his name is Pastor Greg Pastor Greg and
I will have extra to talk about on
Sunday hahaha there's a little laughing
face emoji yes of course we go to church
because we are sinners in this Fallen
World we're we're subject to
concupiscence and sin and death purvey
the world and you know it's a tough go
of it here and it's a pilgrimage and we
pray for grace of course there but for
the grace of God go I or all men sin and
fall short of the glory of God
you don't need to brag about it
because that will one suggest that
you're not really sorry for your sins
you haven't really repented you're just
brazenly
continuing in a state of grave mortal
sin which again describes a lot of the
world the difference is you're at least
putatively a Christian at a Christian
prayer breakfast
and and then furthermore you are
incurring the sin of Scandal because
you're leading others astray by saying
this is what Christians do and you're
you're implicating your pastor in that
sin also I I recognize it's a very
messed up culture and catechesis is
really weak these days and people don't
really know how they're supposed to
behave I have a great deal of sympathy
and empathy even for all of that but
this is a real indictment uh of this
lady's pastor of whatever ecclesial
Community Pastor Greg seems to be
leading it doesn't seem to be forming
Souls all that well if these are the
kind of jokes that his flock make at at
National Prayer breakfasts
and it raises the question why was she
invited to speak what
ah man what are these people going after
it's the conservatives and the the
nominal Christians in our culture what
are they going after when you want to be
sure of something
like a good dinner you got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
you know that I love anything made with
top of the line quality for meat that's
good ranchers the only thing missing
is a pork box okay I've said it for a
long time well if you ask for it they
deliver good ranchers has just launched
their Prime pork 100 American pork that
is Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone in which is my favorite
and boneless pork chops sausage smoked
brats and more plus right now you will
get 30 bucks off with code Knolls at
goodranchers.com on their site you can
explore their All-American cuts of prime
pork prime beef better than organic
chicken options if you've tried their
beef and chicken before you know how
amazing it is I have said this for a
long time I fear that I haven't conveyed
it there is no service on the market
that gets you anywhere near the quality
of good ranchers and good ranchers has
the most competitive prices around it's
one of the few things I missed when I
was in Hungary head on over right now go
to goodranchors.com use code knows 30
bucks off any box that is promo code
Knowles kwles goodranchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
do they want to
establish a big tent and accommodate
themselves to the way of the world in
the way of the decadent degraded liberal
culture
to try to win some elections or fill up
the pews or something like that
or do they want to speak the truth and
speak the truth come what may because to
to win this some kind of nominal Victory
by adopting all of your opponents
beliefs and premises and behaviors is no
victory at all it's a pyrrhic victory
it's a concession it's a surrender it's
a loss
it's like that good old line which I'll
attribute to Fulton Sheen a few
different people lay claim to this line
if you marry yourself to the spirit of
the age you'll find yourself a widow in
the next
if you if you wedge yourself to the
spirit of liberalism as a conservative
then you haven't won anything you're
just you're just you're a big lip and
this is of course especially true in the
case if you're a Christian and you say
I'm a Christian but I just do all the
things that the world tell me to do and
I just try to seem cool by the standards
of this Fallen World which is under the
rule of of the Devil Himself then that's
not a victory man that's a loss then
what does it even mean to say you're a
Christian you know I was in Hungary last
week and I'll I'll publish the text of
my speech that I gave at the big
political conference there I'll publish
it on daily wire and I think there's
going to be a video that goes up soon
enough but the topic of my speech was
now salvation hinges on the flesh which
is a line from turtle and the early
Christian writer that the flesh itself
is the hinge of Salvation in modernity
we like to think that
my faith is just something that lives in
my head you know look maybe I sin all
the time and I lead others into sin and
I laugh about it and I brag about it and
I don't do anything to try to stop it
but hey if I think in my head that I'm a
Christian that I'm a Christian
even in the political Realm I I can lit
I can move to a city I cannot get
married I cannot have kids I cannot take
virtue seriously I cannot go to church I
cannot do anything other than go to
brunch and live according to the modern
liberal culture but if I tell myself I'm
a conservative then I'm a conservative
no man you got to do it we live in time
and space we and especially when we're
talking about Christianity we're talking
about a religion that views the
Incarnation and the crucifixion and the
resurrection as the very pivot and
meaning of History it's the most
historically focused religion that there
is meaning time and space and actions of
real men in flesh and blood in places
Hungary gets this is which is why
Hungary has reordered its law and its
culture to better accommodate people who
are trying to pursue goodness and truth
and Beauty you see in the beauty of the
buildings that the the government is
actively trying to restore you see this
in the truth of the Eternal principles
that the government is enshrining in its
Constitution and its laws and you see
this in the clear moral Vision that that
the Hungarian government has laid out
which is nothing new it's just the
traditional moral vision of our
Christian civilization which the liberal
societies either ignore or invert and
say that good is evil and evil is good
that's you got to do stuff and let's say
that Nancy Mays keeps sinning or
whatever you know we all sin at
different times but
we should be ashamed of that we should
not brag about it in public we should go
seek Absolution and forgiveness boy what
a great clip that was now make sure that
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel see you
next time